yes yeah yeah back to what we were
talking about
black holes creating black holes at cern
so let's talk about what a black hole is
so a black hole is basically
a object whose gravitational strength is
so strong that light doesn't escape
it but what matters is
two things a how big it is in other
words how
what's its mass but secondly where
that actually occurs where the strength
is so strong that light doesn't escape
it is dependent on how far away you are
from it
so in the terms of gargantuan right it
was a superman we're talking about a
star in that case
was probably i i don't know in terms of
what kip thorne was thinking
but i imagine that it was roughly
the size of let's say uh half of the
solar system
it was a huge thing right we're talking
about if you place gargantuan where the
sun
is it would stretch right past where
earth is so we're talking about a really
really really big object right
if i flip that around and said let's
let's make the sun
the black hole shrink it down right
we're now
dealing with an object that is smaller
than the city of new york
right we're not dealing with a really
big object
but the mass of it is still the same
which means that if i did that the earth
wouldn't
get sucked in murky wouldn't get sucked
in that all stay
in their orbit exactly the same thing
because they're still that distance away
from the center you have to be really
close and i'm talking about in this case
you have to be really
meters from it right or the
uh the mathematics basically it says
maybe only a couple of kilometers from
it
um for it to actually really start being
so strong that
light can't escape it so
if you get that concept the fact that
if a black if we create a black hole the
only ability
of it to suck matter in means it has to
have a very strong gravitational field
very very close to it right
so let's now go to our
primordial black holes which soon
hypothetically
could make um they don't make it by the
way
they at the moment that they don't have
the energy
requirements to do that okay um
we're dealing here with objects that are
to the order of the size i say 10 to the
power of negative 35 meters now that
number means
nothing but if
i were to take a primordial
black hole so to speak and increase
it to the size of a a let's say um
why is it called a primordial black hole
okay because we believe
and this is the reason why is because i
believe that the early part of the big
bang
early part of the universe created these
little primordial black holes
okay the theory suggests the
mathematical theory suggests
they were part of the early stages of
the universe and i'm talking about the
early
fractions of a second of the big bang
right and this is what cern is trying to
do so look
it's not just about what matter is made
up of but can we
somehow create in a very very very small
space and i make that point particular
clearly because a lot of conspiracy
theorists get this
wrong they want to create the early
conditions of the of the
big bang right and they go oh
all that energy it's dangerous and so
forth but hold on we're talking about
energy in it
really really really really tiny small
space
so we're not talking about a huge amount
of energy
overall we're talking about a really
compact amount of energy
in a really really small space you know
to give you an analogy right if i
got if you've ever seen hopefully
terminator 2 where annie sinks into the
v
the vat of molten iron and i say how how
hot is that it's about a thousand
degrees well that's
hot right or that 1000 degrees celsius
so about 2
000 fahrenheit um and then i say
to my students what about those
sparklers that you have at new year's
eve parties
how hot are they and they go oh that's
not hot well it's actually i say
it's about the same temperature it's
about 2000 degrees fahrenheit or 1000
degrees celsius
and they go what what's go it's because
that energy is packed in a really really
really small spot
it's not the total no no it's packed in
a really really small spot and that's
what temperature is
temperature is a measurement of how much
energy is in a really really really
small spa
and so when you know it's not the total
and so when we say we want to create the
conditions of the early big bang
we want to create the same temperatures
in a really really small spot
but it's not a total amount of energy in
the sense of all-encompassing destroy
the world type of energy
in any expression does that make sense
total totally makes sense
i guess the question is like can they
can they can
slip out of their hands and can it just
expand
beyond their control without them under
with i think a lot of people just don't
understand what you just described
okay of course it's good slip on your
hand have you ever had a sparkler
get out of control and the sparks lay in
your hand does your hands suddenly
explode
it could like it could light a fort it
could let your house on fire
right oh yes that's true but we're
dealing here with
okay it's got to ignite something else
that is itself got
to stored energy you know if i sparkler
hits a vat of of uh
of gasoline uh yeah that's dangerous but
it's not the sparks problem
it's the fact that you had gasoline
beside you that could react with that
little bit of energy
and in the end of in the case of the big
bang uh the the cern hadron collider
the amount of energy in those collisions
it did actually happen
in terms of they had an a a
an accident now people go oh accident
but again put this into context
the way that cern's particle
accelerators work is that they have to
create these really really powerful
magnets to
make that turn around that 27 kilometer
loop
and the only way you can make those
really powerful magnets is using what we
refer to as electromagnets so
you know a electromagnet most people
know basically it's a coil
if you run a kind through it it has acts
as a magnet
and your doorbell works on that
principle
but the problem is if you want a strong
magnetic field you need a very strong
kind
and if you want a strong current you
need a car that's so high
that doesn't melt the wire so what they
do is they cool
these electromagnets down to
under 3 kelvin now to give you
perspective
that's minus 456 degrees
fahrenheit so we're talking about really
cold
temperatures that they keep this in and
um only then can they have the magnetic
field strong enough to
turn my head ons around now
in 2008 when they first ran the machine
the beam actually lost its
direction and it hit the sides of the
tube that was in
problem there is it heated up the side
of the
tube which caused the
gas the helium in this case helium was
the liquid it's liquid helium that's
that temperature
caused it to raise in temperature all of
a sudden
the electromagnets weren't working
properly because the temperature was
higher
and as a result this liquid helium went
from a liquid state to instantly gas
state while the gas expands
and as a result it blew a hole in the
pipe
now that hole in the pipe damaged a
number of
electromagnets in there but it wasn't
the case of the
total destruction no no it was basically
a gas release an explosion and caused
instrument but that was the end of the
story you know like it took a few months
to fix it up
so you can't make this energy escape you
know
another way of thinking about it is that
the energy of these collisions that's
occurring here
between these two protons is equivalent
to the energy of a beating mosquito
that amount of energy right remember the
energy we're talking about is not is
all-encompassing energy you know it's
the energy in a really really tiny spot
but if you want to work out well how
much energy is actually there
well it's equivalent to a mosquito right
so
um we're not dealing with
world destroying energies amount
here we're dealing with temperatures
in a really really confined spot and
even if it does run out of control
yes it might damage the equipment but
it's not going to be a case of
you know it's not going to be an
explosion or you know
just you know you know
put it this way the people in geneva
have got nothing to worry about and
cern's based into geneva
right if something happened in cern they
would never know about it in fact if you
were just
across the border in france in the small
town and i've crossed that border
literally it's 10 meters away from one
of the um
from one of the um detectors um if
something happened you wouldn't know
about it
because the amount of energy released is
extremely small
in the total amount if it happened if
that makes sense
absolutely we haven't answered the black
hole question yet right right right
right
so the black hole these primordial black
holes are incredibly small
right we're not dealing with gargantuan
sizes and i said to you how about we try
to
get a perspective of how small these
black holes are
if i were to take these primordial black
holes and
magnified its size to about the size of
about a millimeter across a few
millimeters across
then comparatively a grain of sand
we get this a grain of sand in that
comparison
will be more than 10 times the size of
our known universe
let me let's stick that with you
let me put it another way if i have a if
i have a gray a millimeter a few
millisecond black hole
okay and i say well what's the size of
an
atom right in that comparison
well the atom would be the size of our
solar
our milky way our galaxy our milky way
so can you see the perspective here i'm
trying to say is is that these black
holes
are not big they are incredibly small
right and the only way they can we can
register their existence
is of their energy that they give off
and we're talking about an incredibly
small amount of energy
right okay so these black holes are
really really small
now people say well so who cares if
they're small they can grow
and i want to give three reasons why you
shouldn't be worried
the first thing is that we the theory is
now clear
you know stephen hawking everyone knows
of stephen hawking yeah
developed a theory that basically black
holes do evaporate they do
actually radiate some energy so over
time they actually shrink
now the rate at which they shrink is
dependent on their size
so the black holes such as in gargantuan
well they would take
trillions literally trillions of years
to evaporate away
but our little tiny quantum black hole
that cern could create
would practically evaporate within a
microsecond
incredibly smaller time they would not
survive long at all so that's the first
reason
the second thing is as i told you
they're so small
that they would not actually be anywhere
near
any other matter to suck energy in
remember my
analogy of my grain of sand right and my
atom is the size of the galaxy
right well what's the likelihood of this
grain of sand or this little tiny
particle
as it moves to actually hit anything
when most of the atom is empty space
right it's highly unlikely to ever ever
ever strike anything now remember it has
to strike something within a given time
and it only lasts a fraction of a
fraction of a second
again it's not going to suck anything in
before it
completely disintegrates
and the last thing is this people say
cern is doing these energy experiments
and they've
it's never been done before and i tell
you actually the energies that cern
does happens every day above our heads
so we have things called cosmic rays
out in space and they strike the
atmosphere
and hit the particles the gas particles
as
you know these cosmic rays come in and
those cosmic rays have energies far
higher than anything that cern has
produced
so in other words what cert is doing is
actually a miniature version of what's
already happening
at our atmosphere and we know this was
we detected
cosmic rays in the 20s and the 30s and
the 40s we know it exists
if they were to get energies
to create black holes and the cosmic
rays were already creating them
in our atmosphere remember these black
holes would probably be created but then
pop out of
existence well we're still here
so the fact is is that if cern was able
to make black holes
then our atmosphere would be creating
them
all the time other stars would be
bombarded either objects other planets
other stars also divided by this cosmic
rays
and um we would be having black holes
being created all the time
now again we're still here that universe
is still here
right so the fact is is that the chances
are is not and i think
part of the problem i think what really
is confusing and i
i'm uh is this the physicists have a
have a tendency to go oh i wonder what
happens and like this and you know
just hypothetically in a very tone loki
and so when they say yeah we might be
able to create make holes and someone
says well
can we be dangerous they're like oh yeah
well and all of a sudden the media grabs
on that it's like oh
that's dangerous and so forth and in
fact john ellis
uh who's a theoretical this is based at
cern i i did
i didn't actually get a chance to talk
to him but i did see him walking around
he does look like a crazy
wild hair a hairy guy he was asked
he's basically asked the same question
can it happen and he simply said
no you know he was blunt as is in the
sense of
no absolutely not